ALEX: It's all happening
on your laptop.
So essentially, this sort
of thing that you've trained
is all sitting on your computer.
So it is an interesting
kind of fork
in the road, where I could
imagine a world where
if that kind of classifier I
had made for my kid's drawing,
would that be something
that I could kind of
grab and share and post?
And so I think that that idea
of you owning a little model
that you've made
was very much what
we wanted to go for
with teachable machine.
But we haven't quite
gotten to that.
That's almost the second
phase of that, hopefully.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks, Alex.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Well, the next
speaker is Patrick Hebron.
He is an Associate Professor
at the New York University
and has worked with Creative
Labs, as well as with Adobe
on the implications of machine
learning for creative work,
and has also published
a book around machine
learning for design.
PATRICK HEBRON: Hey.
I want to thank the
organizers for having me.
It's really an honor to be here.
OK.
Whoops.
So this talk's about
making machine learning
tools more accessible.
But it's not about dumbing
them down for lay audiences
or about creating toy
interfaces for toy problems.
Obviously, there's
a lot of differences
between human and
machine learners,
but we all have ample
experience with, perhaps,
the most fundamental
element of machine learning,
which is that we know how
to learn from experience.
And in fact, the most
challenging thing
about learning how
to teach someone else
is kind of remembering
how you came
to know something yourself.
This metacognitive ability is
really a very precious and hard
won skill.
Obviously, it's very much in
the wheel house of educators,
but it's also a key component
of all of our interactions
with other people.
When we teach our
children to ride bikes,
we don't rattle off exact
programmatic procedures.
We, instead, demonstrate, watch
as they approximate the action,
and help to direct the child's
focus to overlooked aspects
of the task.
Machine learning
tools should help
us to do exactly those
things for machines,
so that they can,
in turn, help us
to solve problems that are
too complex to be addressed
by conventional code.
And also tools that
help us to sharpen
these kinds of
metacognitive abilities
will not only help us to
build more useful machines,
but they'll help
us to understand
ourselves more deeply
and engage with the world
more effectively.
So when I say accessible, I
mean that machine learning tools
should be able to service the
extension of every human's
kind of innate
capacity to both learn
and teach from experience.
Machine learning is
a tool for everyone.
But in its current form, that's
not really all that obvious.
Presently, machine
learning tools
requires some programming
skills, some understanding
of the fundamental
techniques in machine
learning, the underlying math,
and probably also some DevOps
skills.
And so in combination, this
presents a really very high
barrier to entry.
The first generations
of tools have
been focused on aiding
expert practitioners
to manage high performance
pipelines at really
very granular levels.
And they've also
abstracted the demands
of machine learning into
conventional programmatic
structures, even
though, in many ways,
there is a kind of incongruity
between the deductive mentality
of conventional code and the
inductive mentality of machine
learning.
The skill that I think is
not really yet accentuated
in machine learning tools--
aside from the things that
Alex was just talking about--
is that these tools
don't accentuate
the skill of curriculum design
or the process of curating
a learner's experience
of a complex concept
and bringing forward
its meaningful elements.
In my teaching work, I've found
that often a person's math
and programming background
is in a lot of ways
not the best predictor of
how they will take to machine
learning work or applied
machine learning work,
and that, in many cases, the
most captivating projects
come from students who are
clear writers or designers.
And I think this is because
what makes a machine learning
project successful is
the student's ability
to articulate a
learning problem, how
a particular concept
can be demonstrated
through a particular
presentation of data.
And this was actually--
wait, it doesn't
look so good but--
this was actually published
just a few days ago.
As mechanisms for neural
architecture and parameter
search become more
robust, then the sort
of current skills in
machine learning work
kind of become somewhat
less vital to applied work.
And the skill of articulating
a learning problem
becomes all the more.
I think this is sort
of analogous to perhaps
in the first 20 years
of computer science,
to be a programmer, you really
had to basically understand
how to implement a compiler.
And as we've moved towards
higher level languages,
that's no longer necessary.
I think we can sort of
see the type of work that
goes into designing a
neural network today
as being that kind of sort
of compiler design aspect.
And so the sort of
more central skill
will become curriculum
design, if you will.
So hopefully this kind of next
generation of machine learning
tools will be able to
serve two audiences.
It will help novices in the
sort of conventional aspects
of programming and
machine learning
to be able to
experiment and explore.
And at the same time,
it can also, I think,
help expert practitioners
to sort of work
within a framework that is more
natural to machine learning
rather than sort of being built
upon the conventional code
mentality.
Traditionally, a
programming language
is treated as distinct from
IDEs and other tools that are
essential to writing software.
These delineations were
probably already pretty outdated
with the advent of
graphical computing.
But in the machine learning age,
they're becoming even more so.
And I think one place
where we can already
see the need for a kind of
a more holistic programming
environment is in the efforts
of DeepMind, and OpenAI,
and others to build simulation
environments for training
reinforcement learning systems.
These are sort of game or
design or physics kinds
of environments and
becoming more and more
central in this graphical and
physical context to building
machine learning systems.
Of course, Jupyter Notebooks,
Matlab, Mathematica, Swift
Processing, and Scratch,
and web development tools
have already kind
of started to blur
these distinctions between
the text editor and a more
cohesive environment.
But there's a long way to go.
The purpose of this is not
only to make the interface more
palatable to the human user,
but also to sort of bridge
the gap between the
computer's understanding
and kind of experiential nature
and, of course, the humans.
So deeper mechanisms
for communication
shouldn't be tacked on to
the existing interfaces
or auxiliary libraries,
they should be brought
into the center of our tools.
And we should also take
this paradigmatic shift
that's brought about
by machine learning
as cause to rethink
numerous aspects of software
development.
If we're making one change,
why not make a bunch?
OK.
So I'd like to show you a little
bit of a project I've been
working on and treat it kind
of as an example of how these
kinds of ideas might
be implemented .
Some of the stuff
we'll talk about
are things I've
already implemented.
Some of them are sort
of longer term horizons.
And I'd be happy
to show any of you
where the current software is.
But for the purpose
of this discussion,
don't want to sort of
focus on that divide,
and instead talk about
this as a whole vision.
So I call it Foil.
And it's supposed to be kind
of a combination of machine
learning and creative
coding platform.
And it's an attempt to close
the loop between programming,
machine learning,
and design tools
in a single platform that can
integrate all of those aspects
that we've talked
about and that's
a pathway for novice to expert.
It envisions a multi-tier
approach in which lower level
features can be used directly
by more experienced users
or could be composited
together to be
used by less experienced users.
And as users gain
experience, the idea
is that these components are not
impenetrable, but instead can
be kind of inspected
under the hood.
So I think we see
some of this going on
with TensorFlows estimators and,
of course, Keras, and so forth.
And I guess one
extension of that
would be to think about
graphical representations,
too, there.
So this is its kind of expert
mode or current statements,
which is roughly equivalent
to Jupyter Notebooks,
but trying to sort of integrate
all of these components
into one place.
This is sort of the jumping
off point for the higher level
functionality I'll
talk about in a moment.
So one of the most intimidating
things about entering machine
learning work is the process
of gaining an intuition
for the role that certain
mathematical operations play
in mechanizing inductive
learning processes.
It was great to see Alex
mention Seymour Papert.
And I won't make a
specific mention here,
but he's sort of the spiritual
guide of all of this.
So I think that
really the challenge
of gaining this
intuition is really not
just limited to those who are
mathematically uninitiated.
And one way to
support this claim
is to look at the, more or less,
300-year gap between Leibniz's
first mention of the
chain rule in calculus
and the advent of the back
propagation algorithm.
So that is to say that
even with an understanding
of the underlying mechanics
and mathematical tools,
it's not always obvious that
a particular application
of those tools will yield
a useful result when
applied to a system that's too
complex to compute mentally.
So to overcome
this challenge, we
need to lower the barrier
to experimentation.
And of course, unguided
experimentation
is, in many cases, unlikely
to arrive from scratch
at the kind of
complex formations we
see in modern neural networks.
But when an experimenter starts
from known mechanisms and moves
outward, as guided by
their project interests,
then it becomes
possible for them
to explore this space in kind
of a more organic matter.
And I think with
the current tools,
this is somewhat
challenging, because a lot
of the examples that we
would seek to learn from
have been sort of
codified by experts
in a very obscure
kind of way, at least
from the point of view of
someone just entering it.
In terms of
architectural components,
I think it's important to take
sort of a multi-tier approach
and provide novices with
extremely high-level building
blocks that address the
basic categories of learning
problems.
Early in their experimentation,
it's sort of unlikely
that they will have cause
to need something other
than these kind of
generalized one size
fits all building blocks,
because they haven't yet
encountered the sort of
deviations from that.
And so a high-level
interface with lightly
customized templates and
under the hood automations
will allow novices
to sort of explore
this idea of how to kind of
frame a learning problem.
And then as they
gain expertise, they
might have cause to start
digging deeper and, of course,
inspecting these components and
going to sort of lower levels.
I guess we could sort
of call this the Keras
layer and the TensorFlow layer.
And so as they gain intuition
and kind of an understanding
of how machine learning works,
through this perspective
of, let's call it,
curriculum design,
then, there may be
eventually kind of a cause
to understand at the lower
level what's going on
in the operations
and start to begin
to think about how to customize
those things for themselves.
Then as an extension of
these building blocks,
the tool ultimately,
I think, needs
to provide a really
extensive Model
Zoo and the infrastructure
for users to share models.
So think of this in three
kind of tiers as well.
The first being that we would
have specified and trained
models, meaning ones
that can be sort of
just pulled directly
off the shelf
and used for, say,
image recognition
and task or something like that.
A specified and
an untrained model
would be one where the
architecture is prespecified
to a particular input image
dimensions and so forth,
but would be untrained.
And then, at the
most general, would
be kind of an unspecified
and untrained model, which
would be, for instance,
say, a multilayer perceptron
architecture that
could be specified
to any particular
kind of problem.
Then similarly, given, of
course, the primacy of data
in--
whoops, sorry-- given
the primacy of data
in constructing machine learning
systems, the development tools,
I think, should also
provide building blocks
to facilitate the loading
and manipulating of data.
Array manipulation's one of
the most common tasks performed
by computer scientists,
but it's also
one of the greatest sources
of frustrations for novices.
And even seasoned
developers find it very time
consuming to understand someone
else's ad hoc code for slicing
complex data.
And depending on what the user
wants to learn from the data,
or what tasks she wants
to perform through it,
the question of how
to slice the data
and what neural
architecture to use
are very much interrelated
considerations.
And so for this reason, it's
important for the components
in data manipulation to be
closely aligned with the tool's
architectural building blocks.
At the highest level,
the tools should
provide interactive mechanisms
for selecting files selecting
from files or media streams.
At sort of a more
slightly lower level,
it should be loaders for common
file types and data sets.
And then at the lowest
level, of course,
you don't want to inhibit
current methodologies,
and so you should also
give programmatic tools
for accessing the file system
and manipulating arrays
in the conventional sense.
Within this, I think
it also makes sense
to support data set maintenance.
So you would have
kind of Watchdogs
that could look for changes
to remote or local file
directories and perform
automatic retraining of models
when updates occur.
And then, finally, sort
of embedded directly
within this kind
of environment, you
would include crowdsourced tools
for either data acquisition
or for cleaning.
OK.
So the next idea I
want to talk about
is something I call directives.
And so the idea is that in
a conventional programming
language, the developer starts
with a nearly blank slate
and needs to conceive of a set
of interrelated abstractions
in order to address some kind of
desired programmatic behavior.
This open-endedness is, of
course, a really great thing.
But it also now requires
us to navigate on our own
each component decision
in relation to each other
and in relation to the whole.
So directives are a mechanism
for helping developers
to structure their thinking
without imposing any one
specific abstraction on it.
In the most basic
sense, directives
are comprised by
a set of widgets
for soliciting multimedia
inputs and presenting
multimedia outputs to the user.
The author of the directive
uses these widgets
to compose a kind of decision
tree or guided process
through which the user can
respond to each decision point
in the most appropriate
modality for the task at hand.
Visual information can
be communicated visually.
And textual information can
be communicated textually.
When a specific numeric value
is needed from the user,
a slider could be presented so
that the user can experiment
within a specific numeric range
and see its effect applied
immediately and in context.
Rather than offering one kind
of preordained mental model,
by offering these in sort of
a Directive Zoo, if you will,
it would provide
developers with a range
of possible abstractions for a
variety of component problems.
And alternately, of course, you
can write your own directives.
And the process of
doing so, I think,
is sort of analogous
to the sense
in which kind of properly
formulating a question
is half the work
of answering it.
So directives are meant to
facilitate software development
processes as kind of a
crowdsourced design pattern,
but they're also something that
can be employed within user
facing applications
to facilitate
interactions with train
models or other features
of an application.
In this sense,
directives are meant
to serve as a way
of kind of blurring
the distinction between the acts
of writing and using software.
In the context of
writing it, it helped
to make it a more manageable
experience for the developer
by breaking the process
into smaller tasks.
And in a user
facing context, they
provide a more natural
format for the kinds
of multimodal
interactions that we'll
need to have with
intelligent applications.
Directives could be
written explicitly as code.
Or, as shown here, they could
be created using directive
making directives.
That would ask questions
like what should the user
do next, a very meta approach.
Directives would
also be something
that could be configured to do
data collection under the hood
in order to feed a learning
decision tree, much
like the digital
version of the game
20 Questions which
is shown here.
This, I think in
a way, could bring
sort of a new way of looking
at the value of open source
software, which
is that by sharing
these kinds of processes
with other users
and allowing them
to engage with them,
their data is informing
the learning decision tree
and, therefore, making
your shared software
that much more effective.
So the last group of
things I want to talk about
is the integration of creative
coding or design tool elements
where we've moved through
machine learning well
beyond the confines
of keyboards and mouse
into a machine's ability
to understand images
and audio streams and videos.
And these forms of media are
very critical to the training
of machine learning
systems and also
to our subsequent
interactions with them.
And our programming tools today
provide very little assistance
with this.
To build a data
set, we generally
kind of are working somewhere
between the operating systems
file, file system conventional
design tools, some ad hoc code.
And so I think both in
terms of curating data sets
and in terms of things like
visualizing training metrics,
it makes a lot of sense to start
kind of embedding these things
into the tool itself.
In the interest of time, let
me sort of get to the point.
OK, so I think there are three
areas where this is relevant.
The first is what
I've just mentioned,
which is to facilitate
the input process,
that we would be
curating data sets
and so forth through this kind
of integrated design tool.
The second is in sort of
the integration of whatever
applications we're building
with these trained models
so that once, you know--
sorry-- a lot of the tools
today would either kind of
go with a RESTful service or
perhaps a messaging protocol
to bridge independent
systems like OSC.
These are, of course,
great solutions, but as
higher bandwidth
systems come into play--
like in this case a
Realtime slam implementation
or a mapping of rooms--
it makes sense to
start to integrate
this kind of
functionality natively
into an environment in
which we can build user
facing applications, so that
people could build things,
use oppose estimation model
to connect skeletal control
in the character in their game,
or an image segmentation model
to build sort of their
own image editing tool.
Sorry.
OK.
So finally just to complete
the loop, developers--
also, as we have talked about
with the reinforcement learning
thing and DeepMind
and OpenAI, the sort
of output of these
applications can then
become kind of new
training input.
So that we could
look at user action
histories to kind
of learn models
where we try to predict
what they would want
to do next or use a physics
environment to build training
inputs for a
reinforcement model.
So finally, I'll just
conclude by saying
that the revolution
in personal computers
only occurred when the tools,
desktop publishing, and so
forth, became accessible
and kind of made
the need for computers
relevant to the everyday person
to build something
for themselves.
I think that this is very much
the case with machine learning.
Until we are able to
use these tools to solve
our own unique problems,
we are at the behest
of prebuilt services.
And so it's very
important for tools
to be able to connect with
people's individual needs.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for that.
I wondered whether you had any
thoughts on two things, really,
one which is forgetting.
Because a lot of
what makes us human
is also to be able to forget
either methodologies for riding
a bike that didn't work out
for us, or people, or events,
or spaces, and whether
there is a role in machine
learning for the idea
of forgetting things.
And the other element
of that is whether--
again, as humans, we're
really terrible at quite a lot
of different things.
And a joke that's doing
the rounds on Twitter
is a concerned teacher, should
I throw myself off a bridge?
Machine learning says, yes,
because the data says yes.
So where in machine learning
and programmatically speaking
do we place decision making
ethics and even identification
that something actually
should never be?
You shouldn't be
doing this at all.
PATRICK HEBRON: Thanks.
That's a great question.
I mean I am certainly
of the opinion
that this is 100% about
humans and that these
are tools to extend our reach.
It's in a very
different form, perhaps,
than sort of previous tools.
I guess we could compare it to
various previous revolutions,
the Industrial Revolution, but,
perhaps, the better comparison
would be to compare it to
the domestication of animals,
perhaps.
But it will go on beyond that.
And I think we don't really
know quite yet whether it's
that or something much more.
Right?
The question of whether we
achieve general intelligence
in machines in any
near-term sort of
will dictate whether
we're talking
more about the
domestication of animals,
or something perhaps
much uglier than that.
And so, you know,
that I guess will
decide some of the history
in relation to your question.
But I think for the time
being, and without being
able to know where we
will be in that respect,
the kinds of things that
we should be focused on
are ways in which people
can tack this on to tasks
that they might
have used, perhaps,
computer science for
previously, but in domains
where basically sort
of explicit procedure
is just not effective.
Oh, and as far
as, yeah, oh well.
Shall I address the
forgetting or leave it there?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, please.
PATRICK HEBRON: Yeah, I mean,
so the task of creating a data
set sort of depends on, again,
sort of what mechanisms occur
in the near term, whether
we sort of get down
to zero shot or one shot kind
of learning mechanisms where
we need far fewer examples.
Obviously, it sort of
plays a big role in
whether the curation
of a data set
is something where an individual
can kind of go in and manicure
things in that way.
Of course, there are a
number of mechanisms on, say,
transfer learning.
And also in the project
that Alex showed,
they are using the nearest
neighbors so that in the end,
the number of examples that
is needed is very small.
So I mean it's a really
interesting question.
And I think I haven't thought
it through sufficiently.
But I guess I could just say
that ideally, this kind of tool
sort of puts it in a much
larger group of people's hands.
And therefore, it is kind of not
so enclave to a people with one
very specialized
skill to kind of make
these decisions for all
of us, but instead that
as each of our sort
of own personal tool,
we can start to make
the curation of what
we want to remember or
forget for ourselves.
SPEAKER 1: Question here?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Me again.
I think your work has
interesting parallels
with end user programming,
end user software engineering,
and end user development
for straightforward software
or straightforward programs.
I think that work has been
around a number of years.
And it rests on making
programming environments easier
for novices.
But also, it uses
an understanding
of what novices and end
users without a background
in programming struggle with.
Right?
So we know that there
are certain things
in computational thinking
that are really, really
difficult to grasp.
What do you think
those challenges
are for machine learning?
What are the tricky things that
ordinary users will trip upon
and that they need
particular support with?
PATRICK HEBRON: Thanks.
That's a great question.
So to go back to the
beginning of your point
that those kinds
of mechanisms exist
in conventional
programming context,
I think one place where that
can be a little misguided in how
people kind of approach the
simplification is to elucidate
an individual mechanism
in programming,
like say a
conditional or a loop,
and kind of go into depth
about sort of exposing that.
But as programmers,
I think what we've
come to realize is that,
ultimately, the thing that
makes programming complicated
is not understanding how
an individual for-loop
works, but about how many,
many of these little
granular building
blocks all kind of
have to work together
in this very complex system.
Right?
And so that's the real
skill in programming
is learning how to sort of
put all of these little pieces
together.
So my purpose in thinking
about this directives concept
is to try to address
that in a way.
Which is to say that it's not
about learning any one building
block, but instead
about the big curation.
And so the attempt
with directives
to kind of think about a way of
not specializing around any one
use case, but sort of
creating a mechanism
by which we can guide ourselves,
or guide other people,
through complicated processes,
not any one specific process,
but that we have, if you will,
a platform for doing that.
So just to sort of
wrap up the answer.
I think in machine
learning, probably
it is in spirit the same issue
as it is in conventional code.
Which is that it's not sort
of the issue of understanding
any one little
specific mechanism,
but understanding how
they all act together.
Right?
So understanding a perceptron,
like a linear neuron
is perhaps not too challenging.
But it doesn't quite
scale up to understand
why this sort of works when
you're dealing with many layers
with millions of
connections between them.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: So the
last speaker is--
and I am going to pronounce
it right Cennydd--
excellent.
Cennydd is a designer
and an author.
And he has been looking
particularly at future ethics.
He's been advising different
companies like Samsung--